[Music]
tonight on brian ross investigates new
questions about the relationship of
sexual predator Jeffrey Epstein with
Donald Trump after NBC News on earth
this footage of Epstein and Trump
partying together in 1992 where does the
investigation go next
Prince Andrew of England and former
President Clinton both had close
relationships with Epstein but they both
deny knowing anything about Epstein's
abuse of underage girls plus the
unfolding scandal in Los Angeles of the
powerful leader of a church with
millions of members also accused of the
rape and abuse of underage girls like
the Epstein allegations the discovery of
graphic videos of his alleged victims
and our shoutout for the reporter whose
first published story led to big changes
in the treatment of women in the state
prisons of Tennessee blind-fire
maybe I'm just not good enough to do
this and then it would be a real
disservice to these people to put this
amateur basically on this this thing
which is essentially their lives from
the law and crime Network studios in New
York City's Herald Square this is Brian
Ross investigates good evening and
welcome tonight disturbing new evidence
in to remarkably similar cases of
wealthy powerful men abusing underage
girls in New York multi-millionaire and
friend of presidents Jeffrey Epstein and
in Los Angeles the leader of a little
dome Church which claims 5 million
members in all 50 states and 57 other
countries we start with the case of
Jeffrey Epstein today in New York a
federal judge ordered Epstein held
without bail while he awaits trial on
sex trafficking charges the case gets a
lot of attention because of Epstein's
powerful friends including Donald Trump
seen in this video NBC News made public
this week showing Trump and Epstein
partying together in 1992 since his
arrest President Trump has gone out of
his way to say he cut off his
relationship with Epstein many years ago
and knows nothing about the abuse
allegations knew him like everybody in
Palm Beach knew I mean people in Palm
Beach knew him he was a fixture in Palm
Beach I had a falling-out with him a
long time ago I don't think I've spoken
to him for 15 years I wasn't a fan I was
not a long time ago I'd say maybe 15
years I was not a fan of his but for
Trump and former President Clinton their
one-time friend chef with Epstein is
sure to be an issue that will not go
away
Trump and others who spent time with
Epstein including Prince Andrew of
England and former President Clinton
have all denied knowing anything about
his abuse of underage girls but lawyer
Bradley Edwards who represents a number
of the victims says anyone who spent
time with Epstein could end up as a
witness there were
of mr. Epstein's who engaged in improper
sexual misconduct at one or more of his
homes we do know that I cannot release
the who's who of who that is I don't
think that going down the path of was it
this person or was it that person we
would literally be here playing the
guessing game all day it's not helpful
for our investigation to reveal those
names but I do think that in due time
the names are going to start coming out
I will say on that topic if you were a
friend or associate of mr. Epstein if
you were regularly in his if you're
regularly with him if you made
observations or heard things it is
important that you come forward and
provide the information that you know
especially if you were not involved in
any misconduct appearing with Everest
was one of his clients one of the dozens
of victims of Jeffrey Epstein who urged
other victims to come forward to make
sure the government pursued the case as
far as it could it's time for the
government to do the right thing for me
and all the other victims still playing
for rights in the CVR a case in florida
this is no surprise that Jeffrey has
was also sexually abusing girls in New
York he did it everywhere and as long as
the victims speak up he isn't going to
get away this time
next the other sex abuse case of another
powerful man the leader of her church
claiming five million members who claims
he is the apostle of Jesus
we're back now with a close look at a
case that is receiving much less
attention than that of Jeffrey Epstein
but is remarkably similar in almost
every aspect a man of power and money
under arrest for abusing underage girls
with graphic new evidence of his alleged
crimes playing out in court they son
joaquin garcia leads a church that calls
itself the light of the world it claims
five million members in 58 countries
including churches in all 50 american
states Garcia says he is the apostle of
Jesus California prosecutors alleged he
used his power in the church to recruit
and abuse and rape underage girls in the
congregation charges he has denied in a
two-day hearing this week in Los Angeles
to determine if joaquin garcia should be
kept behind bars while he awaits trial
the state attorney general's prosecutors
revealed some of the sordid evidence
they say they have against us the first
witness with department of justice task
force agent Steven Stover girls another
agent Troy Holmes described the millions
of dollars flowing into Garcia's bank
account Wells Fargo the city was called
a suspicious activity report or commonly
known as a SAR and it had information
that they thought was suspicious
yes what king Garcia's lawyers told the
judge he should be released first my
client has no criminal record - no
history of flight risk my client has no
history of flight risk
he should be getting bail at schedule in
order for no bail to happen it has to be
a substantial deviation the Attorney
General's Office strongly disagree
I think if ever there was a case a
sexual assault case that deserves no
bail in this case in this instance the
charges are true and the charges are
serious and they are violent against
young girls in this case we have a
situation where we have a defendant who
has used his power in the church to take
advantage of girls he has used
co-defendants to solicit young girls and
prosecutors said there is evidence that
the church leader was helped in the
abuse of the young girls by their own
parents facilitate their use so we're in
a situation where all the other young
women who made the defendant may have
access to all the other young women who
are part of a community that that folks
like the co-defendants might recruit
girls from have no one the judge in the
case ruled he had heard enough that the
church leader might bodily harm those
young women who agreed to testify
against
yesterday I do find that there is enough
evidence to sustain a conviction because
in this case you have very detailed
allegations by Jane bills one two three
and four
you also have an inordinate amount of
the pornography child pornography videos
on mr. Garcia's telephone an iPad and
reason and common sense dictates it's
the work and that's know beyond a
reasonable doubt we use reason to use
common sense that these images are mr.
Garcia's but these were not somehow
planted on his phone by some sort of
conspiracy against it so I find that in
this case that there is certainly enough
evidence to sustain a conviction and I
do find that he is a great risk to the
community the use of religion in this
case the way he has power over these
people as a leader of this church I mean
he religion was used against these girls
they were told they didn't comply they
were sinning he they were told that if
the King can have mistresses and what is
particularly disturbing to the court is
the allegation that essentially that
they would be going against God if they
disobeyed the apostle that is defendant
Garcia and that essentially because he
is he possibly he had carte blanche and
you do what he want
the case against joaquin garcia is being
closely followed by people in the small
Georgia town of flowery branch his
church has been buying a property there
and making plans to create a huge
religious complex with shopping malls
and restaurants that could accommodate
more than a hundred thousand people
efforts by local residents to block the
project have now taken on at an urgency
with the criminal charges against the
church leaders and several of his key
lieutenants journey is now to talk about
that from flowery branch is Doug Davis
who's been helping to lead the efforts
to block the church project mr. Davis
thanks for joining us how close are you
to the church property carbine thank you
for having me why are you behind me
approximately 50 yards away is where the
church property begins and this is just
this is the the large parcel the 300
acre parcel and there are several others
that they have purchased along this road
about a dozen and all so what's been
your reaction and the reaction of others
and Flowery Branch to the charges
brought against joaquin garcia well
that's it's been very two-sided to tell
you the truth we don't want to hear
about anyone being victimized especially
children with it what we're we're
heartbroken for the people that have had
to endure this but on the other side of
the coin Brian where we're almost
jubilant and we feel a sense of
validation in the fight that we've been
you know trying to stop this complex
from being built in our neighborhood so
it's it's bittersweet and what is it
about the property being built in your
neighborhood that bothers you
well for one but this is going to be a
mostly tax-free entity because it is
religious we live in a small town and we
cannot facilitate and manage to do you
know it's gonna put a strain on our
schools it's gonna put a strain on our
taxes and our property values and we
have approximately 8,000 people in our
city and they are talking about
permanently moving three times that and
to an area of 300 yeah
yeah 300 acres and once a year they have
the holy supper that can be from 150 to
200 thousand people
we're just not equipped to deal with
that sort of influx of people here we
are a small town we live here and love
it here because we have that small town
a peace of mind yeah we like to be able
to know our neighbors and to run into
people that we know with the grocery
stores and and it just doesn't
facilitate the type of life that we
would want for our children with that
many people moving into our area
mr. Davis we have a question for you
from our control room from executive
producer Rhonda Schwartz I helping
Rhonda moment Rhonda your question you
first knew that it just was a church
moving in was there concern because it
was a church oh no ma'am
there was there's no concern about it
being a church in specific but once we
got the copy of the master plan for what
they were planning on putting over here
and for the amount of people that it was
going to house that's when the the
concerns really started we are not
prepared for the triple our population
in just this small area there are three
grocery stores within reasonable
distance of our homes and there's no way
that we could that the grocery store
could even keep food in stock or that
kind of that population of people
mr. Davis the church leaders have
claimed it's times that you are racist
that you're opposed to this church
because so many of its members are from
south of the border yes I've seen the
video where Jack Freeman has I said that
this is a holy war against us and that
we are we're trying to run them out and
that we're racist but the fact of the
matter is this is our home no one's
trying to run them out we were we are
here we do not want our way of life and
our community compromised this has
nothing to do with race we have got
people from all over the place that
already live here in Flowery Branch and
we love them all and welcome them all
equally it's just a matter of whenever
something of this magnitude tries to set
up shop in a Stein of this size it is a
Posterous
this is the size of our largest small
here which is about 20 minutes from us
is approximately the size of what
they're trying to put across the street
from our homes and it's just I just
don't see any way that we could all
coexist without our community suffering
mr. Davis we'll only have about 30
seconds left but are you concerned about
the tactics of the church some of their
ministers have said they're going to war
with you yes sir and it is a little
unnerving because we don't feel like we
are in a war I mean we feel like we are
protecting our way of life in our
community and we're trying to do the
right thing for the lives of our
children and or you know they're our
quality of life we are not waging a war
against anybody we are just trying to
try to hold on to the peace of mind that
we have and and take care of what's ours
we we don't want to be ran out of our
homes and out of our community but if
they wanted to go about it a different
way we would have welcomed them with
open arms well Doug Davis and Flowery
Branch thank you for joining us keep us
posted and all the developments there
I'm sure there are more to come you bet
up next our shoutout for the reporter
who first published story revealed
shocking conditions for women as young
as 16 being held inside Tennessee
prisons when we come back
and our shutout tonight for a rookie
journalist who showed right away on his
very first assignment he's a real pro
diving into the use of solitary
confinement for prisoners a practice
that many leading criminologist say
amongst a torture when used over long
periods of time the untold story of what
was happening in the tennessee prison
system to women as young as 16 was the
first story ever published by a graduate
student named Ellen Arthur's I mean
outside of a class by far the biggest
thing I've ever written the first thing
I had really published what Arthur
discovered with the team from The
Tennessean newspaper and USA Today was
dozens of women locked up in solitary
confinement for months and months simply
because they had medical conditions or
behavioral issues local jails could not
accommodate my first thought was sort of
disbelief but then the more I learned
about it the more I started to feel if
not injustice definitely a sense of a a
sadness that a lot of people were stuck
in this position Arthur who was active
in trying to help people who have been
in prison with a streaming video art
show connected with a whistleblower to
help him dr. Allie winters a senior
clinical therapist who helped him and
his readers understand the toll of
lengthy solitary confinement everybody
changes everybody there you you cannot
go into solid a human being cannot go
into solitary confinement and not change
I don't think I was the first person she
tried to reach out to it might have been
the least likely at grad school
journalism student in New York City but
for whatever reason nobody else ran with
it and I did and fortunately were able
to make some impact Arthur's printed
stories and a companion video produced
by The Tennessean and the nonprofit
Marshall project told a compelling story
featuring the plight of some of the
women who had
and through it she said your appraisin
you know I made it a crime I said I've
not been found guilty of that crime yet
it's never easy to hear people in these
cases I'm I'm pretty much asking people
to recount the worst moment of their
life and sometimes the worst years of
their life and it's it it certainly
takes a mental toll on them and it takes
a mental toll on me any journalist who's
reported on this kind of thing can vouch
for that and you know it's I cared about
these people you know not you know some
of them had done bad things in their
lives for sure but I felt for them
believed they deserve their day in court
but as a rookie investigative journalist
Arthur says he was worried he wasn't up
to the task I thought maybe I'm just not
good enough to do this and that it would
be a real disservice to these people to
put this amateur basically on this this
thing which is essentially their lives
that I had to get it right because if I
didn't you know they're recounting these
very painful things that they've never
had a chance to talk about and if I
botched that I would never forgive
myself his stories became big news in
Tennessee helping lead to the release of
some of the teenagers who had been
locked up in solitary confinement a 16
year old is out of prison tonight after
a nonprofit paid her $60,000 bail Fox 13
Zack Crenshaw was there as Rosalind
Holmes reunited with some of her family
members in her slippers and khakis 16
year old Rosalind Byrd was on the
outside for the first time in more than
three months my boy and the stories led
to a new law signed by the governor that
essentially curbed the practice for
minors in ordered better oversight would
involving adults the legislation that
was introduced as a result was was
introduced by a Democrat and a
Republican so it was it was you know
pretty bipartisan and the governor said
you know I'll sign it the idea that
maybe one person or two people could get
out of
of solitary confinement because of this
I think was a responsibility to them a
responsibility to dr. winters for what
she had witnessed which takes its own
toll I think that was in the forefront
of my mind it was just you can't let
these people down they stuck it out
through this the least you can do is
finish this story and you did I did I
finished it in the hospital room the
night my son was born while my wife and
baby were asleep a life-changing moment
for everyone involved congratulations
Alan Arthur on your son and your story
well that's our program for tonight
thanks for joining us we'll see you back
here next week good night